cinq ans après coucou les revoilà
ensemble patrick dewaere c'est lui
gérard depardieu c'est l'autre cinq ans
après les valseuses
ils se retrouvent sur le même plateau
avec carole laure pour remplacer miu miu
et une quarantaine de jeunes petits
gamins belge
et toujours avec bertrand blier
réalisateur et scénariste de ce film qui
sortira en janvier 78 et qui s'appelle
préparez vos mouchoirs
alors quelle est la différence entre les
valseuses et préparez vos mouchoirs
je pense que d'abord sont deux films qui
vont avoir un petit air de famille mais
la grande différence c'est tout les
valseuses c'était une histoire très
agressive tandis que préparez vos
mouchoirs est plutôt une histoire douce
new star tendre disons que c'est une
histoire d'amour
l'histoire d'amour entre quatre
personnages une femme deux hommes et un
enfant
les deux mecs sont toujours les ringards
puis il l'a nadal se tirera avec
mec quoi fait les mesures jeu n'aura pas
les mêmes coûts les mêmes nous ennuie
que dans les valseuses
mais il sera là même truculent ce sera
drôle parce que quand on a affaire à
deux paumés comme eux qui vont se
trouver dans la situation plutôt
burlesque
préparez vos mouchoirs plutôt pour rire
que pour pleurer un côté et collégiens
dissiper créé très dissipée
lui c'est riton vedettes d'un jour jeune
belge barbouillé de petits suisses de
quoi rire bien fort il y a dans ce film
de bonnes grosses ficelles inusable il y
a aussi parfois un goût amer pour
chercher à constituer les valseuses de
son crayon on cherche pas constitué rien
du tout les 25 heures des tellement
nombreux et c'est ça on s'était
tellement marrer pendant les valseuses
que on a eu envie simplement de
retravailler ensemble quoi oublier m'a
dit qu'on allait faire
voilà il ya 50 de verre et depardieu ont
fait les valseuses plus d'un million
d'entrées mieux que delon et belmondo
réunis dans borsalino il avait fait cela
pour une poignée de cloud aujourd'hui
rebelote budget 950 me lie les deux
stars de la nouvelle génération ne se
monte pas sur les pieds accords parfaits
ils sont capables de tout surtout de
rire en forme les mêmes blagues
du tout
n'est ce pas ces retrouvailles à pic
avec patrick impeccable patrick leroux
bertrand blier billets ça va très très
bien mieux que dans les valseuses parce
que je crois que tout le monde a fait un
petit peu de chemin dans le bon sens
même bertrand avec son calme en août ce
qui a été j'ai bien ramasser mais ça y
est fait se stationner c'est très bien
parce que maintenant c'est le verbe et
et plus rigoureux c'est un film si nikos
ans billet du terme
je ne sais pas je ne me rends pas compte
à quel point je j'écris les jeux
cyniques pour moi ça ne l'est pas
tellement disons qu'à une certaine forme
d'humour que j'affectionne et que
j'affectionne particulièrement avec des
gens comme depardieu et de verre parce
que je passe quand on s'entend bien que
on rit des mêmes choses
maintenant est ce que ça sera cynique
pour ce pur ya certaines personnes pour
lesquelles tout est cynique et que c'est
plus la comtesse de ségur ça devient
cynique
[Musique]